even taken the role of batman these
[ __ ] fans are insane with this [ __ ] i
remember when um michael keaton became
batman based [ __ ] on that guy remember
it was first announced he got the part
no no matter who gets that role they go
he's an [ __ ] and he can't handle it
you must have really been hurt by those
comments i i was hurt i was lesser than
i would have been 10 years earlier but i
was hurt because i felt like wait a
minute come on what do i got to do you
know what i mean like i'm just you know
like jesus christ like i thought it was
an interesting idea
um but you know what i also realized at
that point like every it's gonna be now
this turns into a petition now they got
this thing everybody
should do that you know you're really a
hundred thousand you signed a [ __ ]
petition like you know you have anything
better to do with your day and sign
petitions it goes to be better but
ironically i mean the reason i did is i
want to move for my kids particularly my
son that they would see and be proud of
and and now i realize like your kids by
definition are never proud of your
movies because they're just like oh my
god you know they love making funny like
my kids only want to see like armageddon
like tell us again about how you're an
astronaut
more of an oil driller you know and they
get joy and that actually what i've
realized is
the great thing about that is i i never
could do that to my phone i couldn't
understand anything like that to my
father not only
but i thought
well what if
he falls apart you know or what if i'm
terrible
the fact that my kids feel safe to me to
say basically like [ __ ] you in your
movies is beautiful
it's it's
it's exactly my daughter goes you know
dad i don't consider film a legitimate
art form i said well
that's your opinion that is healthy less
than behavior they need to individually
they need to tell you [ __ ] yourself to
varying degrees now i'm still i'm close
to them i'm here they know
i actually think i'm so because i'm
divorced and i got half the time and i
try to i'm still i'm a little like i'm
probably over the top in their eyes i'm
trying to jam a full week of dad into
three and a half days and i'm like out
there jumping rope who wants to play a
game shoot some ladders i'm 16 years old
you know what i mean and i'll try to get
down with him so who's on the who's on
the radio who's this thing or she she
really slaps you know they're like would
you get the [ __ ] out of my room
i don't even know anybody is i mean
nothing makes you feel uncool like being
a father you really realize i don't know
[ __ ] thing about what's going on here
and i can't fake it because they can see
right through you and they'll just be
like
like for for i started studying when i
started getting stoma
i i started i read this book i started
meditating i got really interested in
buddhism it was the first time i read
about anything religious wise even
though it's not theistic that really
made sense to me and so occasionally
like you know i'll tell you guys well
you know buddhism wow you know hey you
know and i don't i don't bang the
[ __ ] book i'm not one of those guys i
know they don't want to hear it but my
teenage daughter just turned to me
one day and said dad
you know what the title of my memoir is
going to be
i was like
no what
my father the buddhist because